you know for two guys who live in
california you'd think we know how to
dress for the beach a little better
i got this fish
in hawaii because if you're gonna eat
seafood you might as well go to the
middle of the ocean to get it today on
worth it we're gonna be trying three
fish dishes at three drastically
different price points to find out which
fish dish is the most worth it at its
price
fish dish bish look at hawaii that's
actually the ocean that's hawaii
we are on the island of oahu oh ahu
in the city of honolulu and that's where
we're pretty much going to be sticking
for this journey maybe we'll come back
some other day
check out the other islands first up
we're going to a place called ahi
assassins
what are we going to be having there
okay wish i brought my swim trunks
i didn't pack for this really
i'm erica i'm the co-owner of ahi
assassin i'm josh coroner of ahi
assassins this is traditional poke here
that we do what is poke in hawaiian just
means to dice or cut poke for us
is fresh fish lightly sauce we want to
bring through the taste of the fish
majority of the time if you come in here
in our first hours you'll see guys
breaking down fish right here how long
have you been fishing
i think i was made on a boat possibly
born right off of a boat on my mom's
side come from a long line of hawaiian
fishermen so did you always think that
you would be a fisherman for work
it was my dream i read the old man in
the sea i'm like that's who i want to be
he was a construction worker and he
would never go to work because he wanted
to catch the augie so we decided to give
it a shot and make it a business
this is all that's left of our first
boat i was wondering like it's kind of a
weird looking door
this boat now rests at the bottom of the
ocean we've still got the door ahi's are
still coming through it do you have
a couple favorites that you could
recommend for us yeah so we are really
popular for our lunatic poke
that's our version of spicy aji i am not
a mayonnaise eater
so we decided to take the mayonnaise out
and add a few other things in there
could you give us a little snapshot of
what is in that sauce oh if i tell you i
got to kill you
talking to a couple assassins i don't
want to i don't want to rub the wrong
way this is a
miniature van that we're sitting in the
trunk of because
ahi assassins not have any sit-down
space in their retail space you take
your bowl
and you eat it anywhere i feel like i'm
channeling josh's story right now i got
sounds of construction
all i want to do is eat fish let's do it
so first the lunatic
yes looks like cartoon rubies little sea
jewels look how juicy they look
it looks extremely juicy i can't do much
more talking because i'm salivating so
much
cheers
oh my god yeah it's so tender
it just like melts this is the real tuna
melts yeah this is the most luxurious
texture i've ever experienced in food
i feel like a bear eating this it's like
i've never had real my god it's like
when you watch sports and you're just
watching from your couch and when you go
to the game in your court side you
actually
see and feel the vibes of the place
courtside with a bad fish
no hesitation
we're going to do hawaiian style which
is our traditional poke hawaiian salt
limu is the seaweed
throw white onions and eno mona a little
bit of hawaiian chili peppers and then
coat that with
sesame oil mix everything around get the
rice in your bowl
top it on top and then that's your final
pokeball so here we have the hawaiian
style
yes
oh god what are you
done this tastes like you're standing on
a beach and just
grab the tuna out of the water you got
all this seaweed stuck to it oh my god i
want to try
all of them my wine is being rewired
right now like the things i knew about
raw fish
and the taste that you could experience
stupid good i wish i didn't know about
this we flew too close to the sun
on the wing of a tuna oh
we use every bit of the ahi in this shop
hawaiians are taught to use your
resources
and steward them well we catch only
sizable fish one hook one line at a time
i'm not thinking about a paycheck for me
thinking about putting food on the table
for
many generations so bones and collars
that's usually trash parts of a fish you
can say
it's not trash that's gold everyone's
favorite is the bag of bones it's when
we get a paper lunch bag
and we just fill it to the top you just
munch down on that is it is like the
whole thing edible at that point being
off of those bones yeah okay
exactly like a chicken wing that bone
means what i'm talking about
yeah i had no idea this was gonna happen
imagine the size of this thing you know
that's like
that on oh how should we attack this
people just like to stick your finger in
it
oh jeez dip it in and you eat it
okay all right i can't wait oh yeah
look at that i just ripped meat off of a
fish's
neck head oh dude it's so fatty and soft
inside
this is where the flavor lives yeah
right off the bone
now i feel like a bear can you imagine
if bears knew what a deep fried fish
last thing i want to talk about is the
aloha spirit uh-huh it's about the
family
it's about the neighbors i think the
outside of this yes
i'm trying to have a sentimental moment
with you bro i gotta find out if i can
eat it
we got leonard's bakery my roommate is
from hawaii and he said we should eat
here
oh man
[Music]
oh oh no it's like eating a big cloud
it's delicious i can live here fish fast
the mucus
producing hagfish can fill a two-gallon
bucket with mucus in minutes when
disturbed
what yeah how big is this fish
we'll try to find a picture and put it
here boop can you imagine producing
gallons of liquid from your body okay
just when you're annoyed i guess that's
kind of like what crying is but if you
cried gallons
and it was thick and viscous yes great
usage of biscuits now we're going to a
place called nw restaurant it is a
husband wife duo
i wonder if they consider each other a
catch
i'm michelle carr oyoka chef owner of mw
restaurant my name is wade oyoka chef
and co-owner of mw restaurant i love the
fork mw it's awesome her cousin actually
designed it for us
that was one of the very few things we
agreed on what kind of restaurant
is mw restaurant we do hoya regional
cuisine hawaii's made up with so many
ethnic backgrounds
so we try to put that all together on
the plate you mainly focus on the
dessert or do you cover
other areas and i think that makes it a
happy marriage too
the front is inside the back is my side
today we're making a dish with this
beautiful
naga that just came in today it's a long
tail red snapper we take the fillet
season with salt we take
blocks of kirimachi and then we grate it
which looks like shredded coconut coat
the fish
and then sear it in a medium to hot pan
for about three to four minutes on each
side we place the fish right on top of
those
noodles and then three small piles of
bonchon vegetables kimchi
bok choy and then some pickled namasu my
mom used to make a deep fried mochi
growing up is one of my favorite things
that's kind of the inspiration of this
dish do you serve the dish now when your
mom comes in the restaurant
yes what does she think about that she
loves it this is delightful did you ever
think you'd have mochi as a crust
for a fish no but now
i'm thinking what else can we crust with
mochi probably anything this is an
unnamed cocktail by the way they
they're still in development it's yuzu
ginger some kind of japanese whiskey
high ball
and a local honey local honey is what
they called me in high school
cheers cheers okay
that's delicious in the world of crunchy
stuff there are all types of different
kinds of crunch you got
your potato chip crunch your carrot
crunch i would most
relate this crunch to the crunch of
popcorn
initially a crunch and then super soft
all the way through on the inside
i'm going to dip this in the sauce
[Music]
slightly sweet slightly salty this is
just like
very slight yeah this is delightful the
snapper flesh itself is like
pads of butter way it flakes apart
yum fish butter i think fish is the
perfect
meat yes it's so tender and light also
did you see the raw snapper
yes it's a beautiful creature people
think horses are beautiful
that is a red ocean dragon i'm not gonna
forget this moment i'll be telling my
kids
and my grandkids about this mochi
crusted fish and i'm going home tomorrow
and i'm gonna try to make this myself
pop this whole thing in your mouth you
want some sauce here take a little bit
of sauce
drizzle yeah his mind's gonna be blown
yeah time for dessert for dessert you'll
be having tropical creamsicle fillet
coconut tapioca on the bottom which is a
playoff of the filipino dish hollow
hollow and then we top it off the
tropical fruits
lilikoi kanten my version of a gummy
bear i love
gummy bears growing up so i take the
lilikoi and then there's a french
dessert called pet different
it's a little bit softer not as chewy
and gummy so i combined the two together
to make that texture of a gummy bear
lilikoi soybean lilikoi custard and then
we burn it with a thin sugar cookie
so it all comes together creme brulee
might be my favorite dessert it's neck
and neck with tiramisu
and carrot cake and gelato i'm ready to
break the crust
[Music]
it's over yeah one fish two fish screw
fishy dessert
oh my god this sorbet inside
is so good i like how you have double
every texture you have something chewy
and something slightly different chewy
the gummy bear cube and the tapioca ball
it's like a gummy bear but it doesn't
have like
the the part of a gummy bear that sticks
your teeth together
i used to be head gummy bears as a kid
oh yeah you got it and then you swap the
heads with the different colors
oh i didn't do that
this is one of the best things we've
ever had chef michelle's mother
hand bakes her grandmother's recipe
cookie cheers
what i'm talking about cheers
[Music]
that's really good you got a fish pack
for me fish fish
actually smell like fish trivia although
many fish bees have not been discovered
yet
right now how many fish species do you
think there are
50 000 you're in the right ballpark the
answer is 27
300. that's a lot of fish species i mean
the ocean is
giant it's like the rest of the world is
living on a one-story building
and the ocean is a thousand-story
building fish on every floor
now we're on our way to chef mavro what
are we eating there
fish
[Music]
my name is george mavro talacitis chef
marvel for
short our executive chef jeremy
shigekane is going to help me in the
kitchen to carve the fish what type of
cuisine do you do here at chef mavro
the french chef in provence was one of
the rare restaurants featuring
provence cuisine from the local market
everybody was cooking french i never
cooked classic in my life and
when i arrived here i did our original
cuisine from a local market at this time
20 years ago
every ingredient and tourist place was
from the mainland really yeah
why even fish i mean they were using
fish from mexico
i got that tell us about the onaga that
you use in this
is the best snapper on the island we
just received the fish
from the fisherman it's gorgeous i took
my inspiration from
recipes that we do in provence i mix the
salt with
egg white and little bit flour to make
sure the salt
keeps together the chili goes on a brown
spinach
on top of the tea leaf to steam the
spinach at the same time
fish on top of the spinach and the top
is protected by the natural skin of the
fish
is the tea leaf a local ingredient as
well yes the chilies
you know the ula dancer when there are
leaves
as a skirt this is still even that's the
way yeah yeah
okay after that i did a very prominent
sauce tomato
shallot a lot of garlic a ton of olive
oil in for once we put a mix of
herbs here i add ogo in the seaweed oh
and suddenly my sausage musumi was
assembled
become
is there a recommended beverage that we
should have along with it yes of course
it's a funny question because i've been
here
for so long trying to sell jose to see
my guest yeah
and nobody said what's that this is
white sea farmer
and no this is jose from provence from
my hometown
he's amazing this is one again with a
combination of seaweed
and tomato so we serve jose from
provence of course thank you
cheers
divine ready to have this fish
[Music]
do you always serve the fish when i can
sometimes we get too busy i cannot
escape
so this guy these guys
all right you cannot eat that use your
own salt even if you want i'm not going
to
enjoy it thank you thank you so much i
did not expect
any of this you literally create a shell
to cook the fish in
i honestly don't know what's happening
here with my nose
fish is in there but there's so much
more happening cheers
what what more unexpected things are
happening right now
i need to take another bite
[Music]
okay well i have to say it's extremely
delicious i've never had
a more perfectly cooked fish i don't
understand what is happening my
expectation going in i was like okay i
know something tastes like a tomato
with leaf and fish for my mouth and it's
not at all that here's my impression of
it and this is going to sound ridiculous
because i know that we just interviewed
a frenchman who moved to hawaii but when
i eat this fish
the first thing i think of is a french
man who moved to hawaii
and made the most delicious fish he
could that's what it tastes like i don't
know
the seaweed inside the sauce is blowing
my mind it all feels like one
delicious mind-melting and heartwarming
texture
it kind of just tastes like that's how
this fish always tasted
yeah i'm trying to think of like what do
things just perfectly come together
i would also never guess spinach was
going to end up in here
oh that looks like a delicious biscuit
that's covered in sugar right now
i want to eat it but i know chef told us
not her taste buds near that
it's amazing this just makes sense it's
light star dust
the movie with robert de niro it seems
crazy but then once you experience it
it's like that's the only way it could
happen
i know this is the end of the fish video
but we're here where the fish get made
one of my favorite episodes that we've
ever done yeah
me too hey oh who's your worth the
winner mw restaurant
they just do such a good job there like
everything is delicious but my worth at
winner
chef mavro no way chef mavro's dish is
the
story of a man who moved to hawaii fell
in love with the island and then created
a masterpiece on a plate i think you
just want to move here i just want to be
chef mavro what was your worth at winner
the pokey
whoa yeah they killed it
literally pokey in general
doesn't really make sense to me other
than here if you're in ohio and eating
poke the cost of fright
it's not sustainable you say fright
fright oh freight
freight freight is it not freight you
said freight the cost of scaring the
fish to death
adam who's you're with a winner the
creme brulee
michelle's creme brulee do i actually
haven't touched the ocean yet since i've
been here
i'm blowing first is it warm
whoa oh
oh it's nice i'll see you in the next
episode what are we doing next bye
bye hi guys hi i want to be a fisherman
you ever fish
a couple times as a kid a lot more
crabbing though i don't know if that
counts as fishing are a crab fish
no they're not you catch a fish you
capture a crab
oh yes